[Musique]
dans le vieux cimetière déploie une
temps bâtir des visiteurs du monde
entier des admirateurs parfois eux-mêmes
magicien amateurs ou professionnels des
passionnés qui savent tout de la vie
étonnante de jean eugène robert houdin
né à blois en 1805 et enterrés ici en
il faut savoir qu'il est effectivement
inhumé ici à blois mais il est décédé
dans sa propriété du prieuré à
saint-gervais-la-forêt le 13 juin 1871
est déclarée en mairie de saint-gervais
et inhumé dans le petit cimetière
communal de saint gervais une première
fois et une fois que la tombe a été
réalisée ici dans le cimetière de la
ville de blois son épouse a fait
transférer sa dépouille ici même alors
dans cette tombe on a toute la famille
ou d'un donc sa fille sa femme sont
inhumés avec lui
[Musique]
saint gervais la forêt à quelques
kilomètres de quoi et la commune ou d'un
achève sa vie à l'âge de 66 ans il y vit
à partir de 1850 de derrière les murs de
cette propriété qu'il transforme peu à
peu en laboratoire d'invention la
première des choses c'est qu'il va
électrifier avec une gâche électrique
l'entrée de son sa propriété pour que
les gens puissent rentrer alors c'est
tout un système qu'il avait mis en place
il va aménager un téléphérique qui va
aménager un télescope pour pouvoir voir
la ville de blois puisque effectivement
son cher pays natal comme il l'appelait
alors pour les habitants c'était un
petit peu particulier puisque c'était il
l'avait surnommé l'homme étrange de
saint gervais
avant cette vie d'inventeurs robert
houdin révolutionne le monde de
l'illusion toutes ces créations de
génial prestidigitateur sont rassemblés
dans la maison de la magie de blois on y
découvre les innombrables facettes d'un
saltimbanque devenu visionnaire il
incarne aujourd'hui cette image de
chercheurs moderne de quelqu'un de
curieux au savoir encyclopédique qui
n'était pas croiser au nez dans ses
connaissances et qui a su surtout qui a
eu l'intelligence
également de s'intéresser aux autres
cultures magique c'est certainement l'un
des magiciens qui a le plus écrit il a
laissé une trace indélébile et surtout
ya creusé un sillon
hilal s'est intéressé aux s'il ya
l'électricité qu'à l'optique des
domaines qui étaient en plein essor à
l'époque et l'horlogerie on peut dire
qu'aujourd'hui c'est le pionnier de
l'horlogerie électrique mondiale
début octobre un événement marquera en
terre blésoise le 150e anniversaire de
la disparition de robert houdin le
conservatoire national des arts de la
magie et de l'illusion espère alors
avoir recueilli les dons nécessaires à
la restauration de la tombe du père de
la magie moderne
[Musique]